hello Hong Kong thanks for hanging
around I will try to deliver um so one
thing I've been thinking a lot about as
I've been spending time walking the
conference hall and spending the day
today in Hong Kong is just the diversity
in the audience of where we come from
what we're trying to achieve and I gave
a lot of thought to what do I really
want to deliver in this keynote how do I
bring value I think one of the things
that you know when I think about
products or services and definitely when
I speak or create content how do you
bring value like what's what's the trade
here I'm getting your attention I want
to bring you value in return and the
thing that really stands out for me is
the one thing that I'm confident in the
one thing that I'm absolutely confident
in is what attaches all of us what is
the one common theme whether you're a
startup whether you're a professional
with your student solo entrepreneur
large company starting tomorrow what is
the one thing that guarantees a
connection point that we can all agree
on and get value out of the framework
that I create here and I think that
comes down to one simple thing that no
matter what you're doing in this room
whether you're trying to raise money for
a non-profit or you're trying to sell a
FinTech product or trying to raise
capital for what you're trying to
achieve the one thing that we all trade
on in this room is attention if you are
not sitting and debating on an everyday
basis on how you as a human or as a
company act like a modern day media
publisher how you communicate whether in
written audio or video form and then
which platforms are under priced and
over priced you are basing missing the
punchline it doesn't matter how good bad
or indifferent your product or services
if nobody knows about it you are
vulnerable and the thing that I'm
curious about is where
everybody in this room is on their
lifecycle because if you've had success
for three or four years you might have
fallen in love with what got you here
the biggest concern I have and I see
some heads nodding already is what got
you here today is always the thing
that's not going to get you to tomorrow
for example for me if you asked me today
what am I most paying attention to where
do I see the next arbitrage
it's absolutely around audio I am
obsessed with what's going in the US
market not only around podcasts and this
is global but especially around what's
going on with Alexa from Amazon Google
home and the future Apple home pod the
one thing I promise you is that every
single person here besides the health
and well-being of their family and money
values time and time is emerging very
quickly if you take a look and this is
extremely prevalent through the Asian
market European markets South American
market US market x value is exceeding on
an everyday basis as we become more busy
we start valuing time tremendously
tremendously that is what uber and other
transportation apps have traded on it's
saving you time even the perception of
time is a good business model but the
thing that I think I'm very fascinated
by is how much sound and audio will be
selling back to you time founded that
you used to not have when you watch a
video which I think we can all agree
video content is scaling and importance
that is absolutely in the prime of its
medium right now when you're looking at
video it is taking up your time audio is
incredibly passive and so the thing that
I'm trying to force down energy-wise in
this keynote is the following number one
no matter what you do for a living you
need to think of yourself as a media
company your company if you were a SAS
tech you were a media company comma SAS
heck if you were a consumer social
network you were a media company comma
social network if you were a human being
you are a media company comma human
being when you wrap your head around
that you start understanding what you
should be doing which is in your natural
way producing stories for people to
consume to bring awareness to what you
do so one if you are not taking this
opportunity for what it is
you've already already put yourself in
second place this is the moment number
two
entrepreneurship got popular and that
means it's dangerous because there's a
lot of people that raise their hands
that have entrepreneurial tendencies and
aren't necessarily entrepreneurs just
because you say you're an entrepreneur
doesn't mean your next successful
entrepreneur and I the reason I bring
that up is not to be like I'm cool
you're now or anything of that nature
there's just one very important thing
that is not being discussed enough we
talked about working smart and having
the right strategy and having the right
product I am stunned by how much
pushback there is when I talk about
working hard there is no zero people you
know that have built a successful
business without working their face off
there are people that have inherited
money there are people that have had
that dynamic but you know nobody nor
does the world that has started from
zero and built something substantial
that hasn't put in a disproportional
amount of work to get there it is the
one uh turley controllable aspect of our
game and if you really want this please
really start thinking about maximizing
every minute that doesn't mean
neglecting your family that doesn't mean
neglecting your health but I am stunned
as somebody who's spending an enormous
amount of time in this ecosystem by how
many people have the ambition and their
mouth is running to what they're gonna
accomplish and their actions don't map
to it at all hope everybody's ready for
this session because I am
Gary are you doing I'm doing well how
are you great hello Hong Kong
so basically we're talking about you
know when you have fears you just don't
give a [ __ ] about it just go for it
hey listen everybody's I'm I'm petrified
of my mother's health like petrified so
I have fear
I just think life's about alternatives
life's like I don't give a [ __ ] when
people talk to me about theory it's
binary like when when your spouse gets
terminally ill theory doesn't matter you
have to navigate when you lose your
biggest client that represents how many
people here have businesses that have
very large clients that represent big
portions of their business raise your
hand how many people here have a client
that represents more than 50% of their
business raise your hand I mean that's
[ __ ] scary for these 11 people like
their businesses suck like not to like
one more time for the 11 of you I want
to give you a piece of ice you need to
like tomorrow like you should leave this
talk right now leave and start getting
other customers cuz that's scary like
who wants to be that vulnerable to
something that they don't control you
know so for me like there's there's just
things that you can't control if the
eleven of them lose that client tomorrow
because the decision-maker
that is their client goes to a different
company and the new one doesn't like
them or that or has a sister that has a
similar business they're in panic mode
they've got to adjust and so you know
you know many people hears businesses
rely on somebody that is not them it is
scary how many people's business is here
that the most important person to the
business is not them that it's a
salesperson that it's a technical lead
co-founder it's somebody else that is
scary and so there's a lot of things we
don't control when we build our
businesses the market don't even listen
I'm a boy that's born in Soviet Russia
you start thinking about
it's where you have to be nice with the
families that run the country [ __ ] right
there's a lot of things we don't talk
about that make it scary which is why I
don't like the current state of
entrepreneurship in the world because it
seems very party and popular and cool
and it is literally everything but I
started my daily vlog yes I like
attention and I want selfies but much
more because I want people to see how
hard it really is how long every day is
if you really want to be successful and
so I'm scared of everything which
actually ironically means I'm scared of
nothing
right that do you understand yeah I got
I got it I know it's a funny little
statement but by accepting yeah
fear of everything it kind of makes me
numb and makes me not fear of anything
anything in what is your advice for
young entrepreneurs in college that are
trying to start businesses and run them
themselves quit college quit college I'm
probably if you're actually an
entrepreneur yes cuz I promise you
college is doing you zero for
entrepreneurship you cannot teach
entrepreneurship in a college
environment because it is an
unbelievable reality of like you have to
navigate it to know what to do are you
collecting debt no okay good well then
then then you just have to decide you
know look what I would tell you to do is
prop you know what I would tell you if
you were my brother if you were a che I
would say you've got to make a decision
either you realize that these are the
last couple years that you could really
really really enjoy and not do [ __ ] and
enjoy them or you could put all your
energy into your business and let your
grades go to [ __ ] and either get kicked
out or let them push you through the
system if if you know you have to also
understand my definition of an
entrepreneur is a little bit different
than I think a lot of people's my
definition of an entrepreneur is you
can't breathe other than when you're
running your business
hello me again
Avram um I would like to thank you so
much first of all I was I've been
watching your talks your videos a lot in
the morning because my mom never
supported me and I had to hear and watch
somebody that will give me this push and
I get it so much for that I really
appreciate I I will tell you that I
apologize for cutting you off
I was so supported by my mom to be an
entrepreneur and I want to remind people
and this is a great crowd to understand
me I was an immigrant if you're an
immigrant where you come from immigrant
parents education is the way out every
Russian Jewish boy and girl that came
from the Soviet Union with my parents
was getting straight A's on their way to
Harvard I was getting straight FS so for
my mom to have the self-esteem to not
care what the other parents thought to
let me do my thing it was such a gift
that I now produce content on a daily
basis because I feel guilty that I had
it so good and I want to provide that
for you guys that is why I do it and so
I think the biggest thing that you need
to understand is the best product will
always win if people know about it
right and so I think the thing that I
spend a lot of time on is I'm a marketer
I like to market
I understand marketing I'm a business
builder I've built businesses I think
there's an incredible interesting kind
of graph between the quality of your
product and how many people know about
it so for example if you're a great
marketer and you listen to everything
that I say and you get a lot of
attention and your business isn't
working a lot of times it happens to do
with your product sucking you know like
we don't spend enough time talking about
the product or service you're selling
you know so please if you're sitting in
the audience and you're looking for the
magic pill or if you think that you're
gonna be able to siphon some information
that's gonna allow you to play in the
edges of the arbitrage of opportunity
please make sure you're looking at your
product and service to make sure it
delivers because if you follow
my blueprint if you get results from my
ideas that you then become an executor
of if your product sucks all that I'm
gonna do is expose your product faster
and you're gonna go out of business
faster so please start there but after
that please understand the following
this is a golden era of marketing for
one simple reason the places where our
attention and our consumers attention
are are now driven by marketplace
bidding dynamics not by writing an
upfront check to get the ads please
understand this please understand that
the biggest difference for us as
communicators is we don't need millions
of dollars to do television and print
and outdoor and direct mail to hit masse
we are trading on marketplaces Google
Facebook snapchat
these are biddable marketplaces the
reason this is the best time is because
those marketplaces are under priced
those marketplaces are under priced
right now because the biggest companies
in the world are not spending enough
money on them you have to understand
when there's a come-to-jesus moment and
the biggest brands in the world properly
spend in everything that I talk about
everything I talk about becomes null and
void we are ridiculously lucky because
we get to navigate through this time for
anybody over 30 and especially if you're
over 40 you really recognize that
because for over 40 crowd here we lived
free internet in a lot of ways the scale
is remarkable the impact is high the
upside is enormous and to be very honest
I think most of us are just taking it
for granted I don't think we understand
the impact of how much the opportunity
is real and for me it becomes
disproportionately compounded because
you're actually at this conference
you're actually part part of a very
small interesting group for me
which is I know how big the opportunity
is I know that 99% of people have no
idea it's happening you do so you're
part of 1% of the whole thing that
understands it's happening now it's
yours to lose
I would argue that if you are not able
to achieve what you want to achieve in
life and you're at this conference
during this time then you really miss
executed then you really got into the
things that I worry about when I put out
content which is you worry way too much
about stuff that does not matter that
you're worried way too much about other
people's opinions which is the biggest
reason you don't take chances because
you worry about how people judge your
failures then then you're doing a lot of
other things that are leading to huge
levels of miss shots and missed
opportunities and so that's why I speak
so much about being insular having the
right intent because literally
fundamentally if you synthesize
everything I've just said non-action is
the fundamental reason that most of you
will fail at this point being in this
room at this conference during this time
and understanding quite a bit of what's
actually happening non-action which if
you take all the way to the seed of a
human being is insecurity which is
probably the biggest reason that I
create content because I hope that you
use me as your shield to do [ __ ] period
boost entrepreneurs in the US which is
oftentimes not always because of
cultural differences but oftentimes you
get to see a preview of what's happening
before it happened when I think about my
friends that have built successful
businesses in Southeast Asia by simply
paying attention of what's happening in
America and then replicating some
version of it in the market it is
literally the dream come true
you know American
entrepreneurs got mad at those brothers
in Germany right who would rip off the
ideas and build a business I always was
so upset about that I mean I think
Facebook has proven that there's no
ripping off if it's a feature and I
think I would also argue that ripping
off by looking at a different business
in a different market and then
interpreting it into your market is far
from ripping off
I think it's called smart so I would
highly recommend I don't know if it's
pride which I think holds back a lot of
people but please take advantage for the
disadvantages one could think they have
there's only five million here if you
want to do it Indonesia if there's a lot
of people but there's so many
microclimates so that's you know so many
different segmentations mainland China
whatever you would deem a disadvantage
please understand you have the greatest
advantage which is 90% of things are
human not cultural 90 percent of things
are human not cultural if you're capable
of understanding the culture of your
consumer and layer the cultural context
on top of the human thing that is
happening in America you are halfway
home
an unbelievable advantage to be an
entrepreneur in this region and watch
things play out by the way for free no
report needed no hiring Boston
Consulting or bein a McKinsey by reading
and watching videos and downloading apps
something that I don't believe most
people in this conference are taking
full advantage of or respecting enough
of how big of an advantage that is and
to me very honestly I'm quite selfish
when I speak I dream in three years from
now you email me nothing would make me
happier than getting an email from
somebody here who said they had a 50
million dollar exit because you know
they just looked at what was working in
America and they built the replica ish
of it here please
do that please understand how big of a
deal that is and I would argue it is
your singular biggest advantage in this
market to be able to be shown what will
work and then allow you to interpret it
oftentimes with very little change in
the model cool cool so those are some of
the top of the funnel things that are
really on my mind I continue to execute
I continue to do I'm I'm very fascinated
by how much time people spend dwelling
and debating I think we glorify strategy
and we underestimate execution I feel
like if you look historically and rewind
the biggest successes the strategy came
from the execution and you did some
Monday Morning Quarterback I'm a real
genius in hindsight because I can
manipulate how I got there after the
fact I'm gonna talk about so many things
in different ways than the intent that
was at first because you don't even
realize that your strategy came from it
because when you're doing the strategy
is happening in real time you almost
forget why you were doing it in the
first place and so I promise you
indecisiveness and debate and
pontificating and ultimately ego is
stopping so many people from being
successful
hi Gary my name is Terence and I'm 20
this year so just one question for you
I've been listening to you for about a
year now and I'm just trying to figure
out as a 20 year without any experience
in my parents business I've wanted to
build a video blog and audio podcast but
I have the experience to actually do it
so which answer should I focus on
building up the experience in the
business or should I go time to help
marketer well listening if you if you
started a podcast and a video blog about
being experienced in the craft that
would be bad faking it but if your
podcast was about the experience of
learning the craft you'd probably have a
lot of 20 year
following you okay so I don't think it's
about getting the experience when I talk
about I built a business for 15 years
before I came out right I say that
because that's what happened but I have
a funny feeling if the internet was
around when I was a kid like this I
might have started documenting my
journey right away
I just wouldn't be walking around like I
was a business building guy I would be
talking about being a young ambitious
guy who used to sell baseball cards and
now I'm about to do it for wine and I
would take people along with my journey
that's my biggest problem with people
that don't have experience they're lying
they're lying that they're business
experts or my favorite you're a 20 year
old life coach because you know you've
lived life so so to me I think you can
start the podcast and the video blog I
mean I wish I did that because I there
was I probably cried cried 50 times in
the first 10 years that I worked with my
dad because they were very painful
fights and that would have been
incredible content that I wish you guys
could watch if you're in a family
business because it turned out okay and
it would have been really cool to see
how that happened and why and how I was
able to give more than I took and how I
loved my dad more than the money and how
I thought about what I could do in my
30s and 40s and it's okay to lose in my
20s but I wouldn't have walked around
and said I was a marketing genius
because I thought I was gonna be